hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker ok
we're on a new set of levels I'm about
nine hoops I was supposed to get that
and this is gonna be a fun no I'll take
the mushroom
who needs fire flower fire flowers is
for quitters who who like to take the
easy way out
wait that's a perfect description of who
I am and what I like to do
why aren't I taking the fire flower
anyway so this is going to be the second
half of this and I'm gonna speed my way
through this because I am a baller shot
caller something-something then and then
and ollar
wait was that the end of the episode
over there was that the end of the level
wait a minute
died like I just miss an opportunity to
finish level because it looks like oh
there's a wooden block there ok so if
there's got to be another way to go
around anyway
like I said if baller shot caller doing
something Hana Hana holler I don't know
how the rest of the song goes if that's
even part of the song or any song that
I'm but never never mind me I'm not I'm
an idiot and I should not holy crap
did you guys see that of course he's on
there go hops in the video but the holy
crap I'm really proud of myself I don't
even know if what I did was all that
amazing it was almost certainly pure
luck but that doesn't matter to me
I like your luck
okay holy crap okay I'm off to a
blazingly good start smooth the hair for
additional power not that I need any
more at the moment but I'm doing fine it
was really cool yeah I I I know I said a
while back that it was probably you know
done with Mario maker but this puts a
new interesting spin on it because this
makes it fresh and unique because it's
always throwing super shuffle Bros it's
always throwing noose hello all right
then
excuse me it's always throwing new and
interesting stuff at me and it's always
of a variety of different levels that I
don't have to like I don't have to I
don't have to do the burden of picking
the levels that I want to play and I
would like to rely on you guys for more
of that stuff but at the same time like
it's sometimes hard to get them because
you have to put in the code and that
slows everything down this is just fast
blazing action why had I not done this
sooner wanna mess with your baby visor
you know I mess with your father enough
it's enough for me no oh my god dammit I
screwed myself there we oh oh I didn't
know you could do that oh that's cool
okay that works for me I knew you could
toss them on your head I didn't know you
just put them on there like that come on
hurry up
tired of waiting for these elevators
right let's go where are we headed where
we headed where we headed where we
headed this way
okay I'm down with it I'm down to clown
Weiss work what's with the time gating
mechanisms up here right okay all right
then oh right at the end here yes
so cool and what's funny I think is like
it always at the end of these ones
you'll always get something unless it's
like only by there based on whether you
get the start out but I'm not on
represent sure on that one oh I almost
beat the world record I was trying to go
as fast as I could just didn't matter we
moving right along late using speed nice
eyes a shirt I didn't even catch the
name of this one but it's a moving one
we're gonna keep did I miss somethin I'm
shaking on this one that there was
supposed to be something there oh maybe
Oh is there oh yeah that would make a
lot more sense than me jumping off into
the abyss the whole reason that I did
that was just so Mario Guth like
questioning every decision that he'd
made up into that point because he just
started jumping off a legend to the
abyss trying to save the princess whoa
hello oh I'm not supposed to move on
that one I'm just posed to let it take
me alright thanks a sure I think that
said the rage of something maybe that's
finally gonna be a difficult level not
that I was eagerly awaiting a difficult
level whoa what Frick is that obviously
it's a fire stick okay moving along this
time we're not gonna suck it up just
carry me carry me oh hello do these
eventually dire or am I just have I
screwed myself over pretty badly
pretty sure I've screwed myself over
this is not fair how is this supposed to
do how am I supposed to okay got in
there whoa oh god this is so scary
checkpoint thank you yes please oh my
gosh I'll need that I appreciate it
you're the best love you mwah
I guess in these are gonna be secret key
doodads
there must have been Oh Frick god dammit
why would you do that to me who's ready
for that oh hello
okay thank you I guess okay we're okay
everything's fine
nothing's cool buildings chill where the
hell am I
Oh God okay let's try this again
boobity boobity thank you I needed that
I lost a couple clones here and there
it's time to get him back and
replenished I could only imagine what
the hell Princess Peach is thinking
right now I mean there's so many like
theories as to why she continually gets
kidnapped Oh God
don't you dare come after me you love me
no I want satires anyway I can only like
there's been a lot of different theories
as to why Princess Peach continually
gets kidnapped from you know the various
ones saying that she's having a secret
affair with King Bowser or King Koopa I
wasn't ready now I have to go get the
keys again god damn it a load of bull
put a bull honkey full load oh [ __ ] you
fans again with less stupid if I have
the stupid spinny do I would be able to
get right past Bowser and I wouldn't
have to worry about it
even with this stupid Chain Chomp that
floppy loop thank you
okay let's try this again with less
stupid how am I supposed to be able to
beat this guy Oh am I supposed to oh
that's handy
thank you whoa almost got lost
whoa cake we're good we're good we're
good oh god that's not what I wanted
okay goodbye
Bowser you have fun with all of your
toys am I going now oh maybe there's
like a who is their secret up there who
is their secret up here I bet there is
hello give me give me give me secret
secret no damn it there's nothing it's
all just a big lie full of lies boink at
least I got the 1up so that's a nice
consolation prize on my misery
alright that was a cool one that was
really interesting it was a bit harder
than the other ones but it was
definitely a lot alright go go go let's
go the rage of Bowser that's what it was
okay I'm with it I'm hip with it I'm hip
to it manually designed cab whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the to have
that back please oh god where am I Oh
manually design chaos my ass what the
hell is this
should I call this level giant mindfuck
of oh wow some of these levels I just
feel like someone just started screaming
at their Wii tablet and just like Oh
make it for me
world record two seconds what was there
just one of the doors that just led
right to the end probably I didn't even
read the level of oh I'm a spring I'm a
spring what does this means it hello
everybody today oh god oh god please
just please I'm begging you I'm begging
you just let me through
just please
I was a spring for that I didn't even
need to be his spring I could have been
anything at all oh wow that was fun this
is fun
I don't want since I played the game and
had a lot of fun like this it's a super
fun so fun man I keep not what is this
what are you what are you what are you
hello a little birdie what are you
supposed to be doing for me I wanna oh
man I panicked so much for no reason oh
wow thank you for the heart I don't know
where I'm going
Oh God I was close the other eye panics
believe I made it out of there oh wow
that was awesome oh that's awesome oh
wow that's awesome okay anyway piranha
Kingdom I'm not a hundred percent sure
why I only saw like three piranhas but
then again my eyes were practically
closed the entire time I was playing
that level in fact I'm not even sure I
was playing I think I just let go of the
wheel thank you Oh classic Mario music
okay am I supposed to take a ride up
here on something am I supposed to be
doing something incredibly important
oh no I'm supposed to go down on that
one Oh God no no no no yes yes I'm
skilled take some of that oh my god damn
it dude
Oh Frick I thought that was a checkpoint
I thought it was what I thought I was
gonna get anything man I'm sweating I
have to end of this yeah I can do this
guy's
I can do this if you just believe in me
what you don't believe in me
well why is that not a surprise I'm not
surprised if you don't believe in me
even I don't believe in me where am I
going
oh I bounced on the bullet crap what was
it Schwartzel Schwartzel why was it
called Schwartzel little arrows called
Schwartzel this is someone in another
language made it someone from the
Schwartzel region come on there we go
all right wink okay now our blazing
speed now we're blazing speed and now
I'm gonna have a showdown with these
aspects here don't even think about it
don't even think about don't even think
our boat it's you're never going to get
me oh [ __ ] they got me blink oh [ __ ]
what bow now we're gonna go down the
traditionally good way whoops never mind
then what the Frick is all this [ __ ]
okay can I please tell me there's
something good in here no it was a coin
oh boy I don't even think oh you can
okay that's helpful
please tell me oh no fire flower is
gonna come out eventually
are you just yanking my yank you're just
yanking my dank aren't you there ain't
gonna be no goddamn fire flower thank
you there we go what took it so long
yeah yeah here we go
alright Bowser [ __ ] time to have a
showdown with diffs [ __ ] alright you
know what [ __ ] you oh god no no please
have mercy have mercy on me of mercy oh
mercy
oh my elevator leave me this is a stupid
you wanna go bro huh you wanna go bro
[ __ ] oh well time for Plan B oh god no
not again not again not again
screw you I'm gonna go back oh flapper
I'm gonna show you who's boss huh you
ain't gonna never be me no one ain't
gonna never be me
you're not me you think you are me
[ __ ] you oh god damn it with the
[ __ ] stupid fire beats crap ass okay
here's my ride my rides are coming I'm
just gonna go for a ride if you get dad
that's cool oh [ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn it
alright I'll catch you next time alright
I'm really gonna show you what for when
I come back come back for the fourth
time it's really gonna be the end of the
road for you let me just wait for my
superpower up here oh god it's my ride
okay wait come back don't leave me ride
[ __ ] now you're gonna get it now you
[ __ ] god damn it again with this I'll
come back again and then you'll really
see [ __ ] no I'm really gonna I'll be
back
[ __ ] me and this [ __ ] you're gonna
get it this time ah [ __ ] my rock my
goddamn ride comeback ride [ __ ] me no I
don't [ __ ] me but you know
okay now you're just gonna die I'm just
gonna stand here and you're gonna die
and you're gonna there you go you died
oh look it's my ride now take my ride up
I'm definitely gonna be the world record
on this one with the blazing speeded
with which which I beat this oh I could
just go down there didn't know that the
one up frankly I thought I did good
enough as it was I have anything with
which to mop off my brow 49 seconds
Jesus that has just gone straight for
the end we're almost done
played through these last few it's just
one word name what is this what is what
it is Wow okay actually what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna stop there I lost track
of time I've actually been recording
this episode for a lot longer than I
intended so I'm gonna end this here and
I'm gonna finish this up in the next one
and then do a couple special bonus
levels that you guys recommend it at the
end of it so thank you everybody so much
for watching I am having a ton of
funnier this is amazing so thanks again
everybody and as always I don't want to
know what those fireballs are that
spells a lot of death for me in the near
future
but thanks again at everybody and as
always I will see you what is going on
in this
ladies gonna get me Oh